Are you good at math or stumped by basic algebra? Hopeless at spelling, but a great test taker? You may have a sense, perhaps instilled early on at school, of your academic ability as a fixed and immutable trait, something that you were born with like the color of your hair or eyes. But over the last several decades, research has suggested that thinking of intelligence this way can sap students' motivation in school and contribute to racial, gender, and socioeconomic achievement gaps. After all, a kid mind think, if I'm bad at math, why should I sign up for an advanced class? Or if I'm not really smart enough to be in college, what's the point of trying?
你擅长数学，还是被基础代数难倒了？对拼写一窍不通，却是个考试高手？你可能对自己的学术能力有一种看法，也许是早年在学校时就形成的，认为它是一种固定不变的特质，就像你的头发或眼睛的颜色一样与生俱来。但在过去几十年里，研究表明，用这种方式看待智力会削弱学生在学校的动机，并加剧种族、性别和社会经济地位方面的成就差距。毕竟，一个孩子可能会想，如果我数学不好，为什么还要报名高级课程呢？或者，如果我根本不够聪明上大学，那努力还有什么意义？
In contrast, having a growth mindset, a belief that intelligence and ability can develop and increase with practice, can help keep students motivated when they face challenges. The concept of a growth mindset has made the leap from the psychology lab to popular culture and even become something of a buzzword in education. but it's also attracted controversy over how much of a difference growth mindset really makes to student achievement. So where is the research now? Can relatively simple interventions, which are exercises really, that reframe students thinking about their own abilities, help close achievement gaps? Whom do these interventions help most and how can they be deployed effectively?
相比之下，拥有成长型思维模式——即相信智力和能力可以通过练习不断发展和提高——可以在学生面对挑战时保持他们的动力。成长型思维模式的概念已经从心理学实验室跃升为流行文化，甚至成为教育界的一个流行词。但它也引发了争议，即成长型思维模式对学生成绩到底有多大影响。那么现在的研究进展如何呢？相对简单的干预措施——也就是重新构建学生对自己能力看法的练习——能否帮助缩小成就差距？这些干预措施对谁的帮助最大，又该如何有效地部署它们？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association, that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. David Yeager, an associate professor of developmental psychology at the University of Texas at Austin, and co-founder of the Texas Behavioral Science and Policy Institute. Dr. Yeager began his career as a middle school English teacher in Tulsa, Oklahoma, but became interested in the science of helping students thrive
欢迎收听“心理学之声”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校发展心理学副教授、德克萨斯州行为科学与政策研究所联合创始人大卫·耶格尔（David Yeager）博士。耶格尔博士的职业生涯始于俄克拉荷马州塔尔萨市的一名初中英语教师，但后来他对帮助学生茁壮成长的科学产生了兴趣，
and returned to graduate school to study with Dr. Carol Dweck, the founder of Growth Mindset Theory. Over the past two decades, Dr. Yeager has studied how to design and implement effective growth mindset interventions, a type of mental exercise that we'll talk more about that help teens overcome psychological barriers that stand in the way of their success. He often focuses on helping students during times of transition, such as transition to middle school, high school, or college. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Yeager. Thank you for having me. Let's start with a definition, which we frequently do on speaking of psychology.
并重返研究生院，师从成长型思维模式理论的创立者卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）博士。在过去二十年中，耶格尔博士一直在研究如何设计和实施有效的成长型思维干预措施——这是一种我们稍后会详细讨论的心理练习，旨在帮助青少年克服阻碍他们成功的心理障碍。他通常专注于在人生过渡期（例如过渡到初中、高中或大学）帮助学生。非常感谢今天能来到我们的节目，耶格尔博士。谢谢邀请我。让我们从一个定义开始，我们在“心理学之声”中经常这样做。
What is a growth mindset? how does it differ from a fixed mindset? So a fixed mindset is the belief that intellectual ability is just fixed. You have a certain amount of it and that's it. That's who you are and that's who you'll stay. That mindset can make challenges and mistakes more threatening because they can reveal deficiencies in your permanent ability. A growth mindset is the belief that students can develop their intellectual abilities
什么是成长型思维模式？它与固定型思维模式有什么不同？固定型思维模式是指认为智力能力是固定不变的信念。你只有一定数量的智力，就这样了。你就是这样的人，也将永远是这样的人。这种思维模式会使挑战和错误更具威胁性，因为它们会暴露你永久能力的缺陷。成长型思维模式则是指相信学生可以通过努力工作、
through hard work, good learning strategies, and lots of help from others, and lots of support and opportunities. So in a growth mindset, taking on challenges and learning from mistakes become ways to develop your abilities. In keeping with explaining our terms, what is a growth mindset intervention? Intervention is one of those words that psychologists like, but I'm not sure that it's really understood by non-psychologists. A growth mindset intervention simply exposes young people to,
良好的学习策略、他人的大量帮助以及大量的支持和机会来发展他们的智力能力。因此，在成长型思维模式下，迎接挑战和从错误中学习成为了发展你能力的方式。为了顺便解释我们的术语，什么是成长型思维干预？“干预”是心理学家喜欢的一个词，但我并不确定非心理学家是否真正理解它。成长型思维干预只是让年轻人接触到，
the true idea that all learning changes us and that learning is possible throughout the lifespan. The way we often accomplish this is by drawing on neuroscience, actually. We explain that learning happens in the brain, that the brain grows new connections when it learns new challenging concepts, and furthermore, that changes in our knowledge and in our brain are possible. under the right conditions and with the right support. So how do you teach this information? Well, you can't just give a dry lecture on neuroscience. That doesn't work.
一个真实的理念：所有的学习都会改变我们，而且学习在整个人生历程中都是可能的。我们实现这一目标的方式通常是借鉴神经科学。我们解释说学习发生在脑海中，大脑在学习新的具有挑战性的概念时会生长出新的连接，此外，在合适的条件和适当的支持下，我们的知识和大脑是有可能发生改变的。那么你如何教导这些信息呢？你不能只是对神经科学做一个枯燥的讲座。那行不通。
Instead, what you need to do is to invite young people into the world in which those ideas could be true. And the way you do that is by providing short but compelling summaries of the scientific information from, and we summarize real studies from neuroscience and the science of human learning. But more importantly, we give them stories. Stories of people who in the past have encountered difficulty,
相反，你需要做的是把年轻人带入那个这些理念可能成真的世界。而你实现这一点的方法是，提供简短但引人入胜的科学信息总结，我们总结了来自神经科学和人类学习科学的真实研究。但更重要的是，我们给他们提供故事。那些过去曾经遇到困难、
have overcome that difficulty by continuing to persevere and develop their skills, and where it becomes true in their experience that learning is possible. The last thing we do in the intervention is we ask participants to tell their own stories. How could this information help you? information help you to address and overcome your own intellectual challenges. Imagine you're a future student coming to ninth grade, starting Algebra 1, wondering if you'll ever figure out how to factor trinomials. In that moment, when you feel dumb at math, how could you think back on the idea that
通过不断坚持和发展技能来克服困难的人的故事，在他们的经历中，学习是可能的这一理念成为了现实。我们在干预中做的最后一件事是，要求参与者讲述他们自己的故事。这些信息如何能帮助你？信息如何能帮助你应对并克服你自己的智力挑战。想象一下，你是一个即将上九年级、开始学习代数1的未来学生，心里琢磨着自己是否能弄懂如何对三项式进行因式分解。在那一刻，当你觉得自己数学很笨时，你该如何回想起这样一个理念：
intelligence is actually not fixed? It's something that could be developed. And what we find is that students love the idea of using their story to inspire future students who might go through the same trials and tribulations. So the intervention is not months or weeks long. It's intentionally short and efficient. So that way, adolescents have the chance to read the ideas, understand them, and internalize them,
智力实际上并不是固定不变的。它是可以发展的东西。我们发现，学生非常喜欢用他们的故事来激励那些可能经历同样考验和磨难的未来学生。因此，干预不是持续数月或数周。它刻意做到简短高效。这样一来，青少年就有机会阅读这些理念、理解它们并将之内化，
without it feeling like people are telling you what to think or telling you how to behave. What were the changes that you were able to measure when you administered this intervention? I know that you had a very large cohort of people you brought together and administered the intervention, and you came up with some pretty interesting results. Yeah, that's a great question.
而不会让人觉得别人在告诉你该怎么想或告诉你该怎么做。当你实施这项干预时，你能够测量到哪些变化？我知道你召集了一个非常庞大的群体来实施这项干预，并且得出了一些非常有趣的结果。是的，这是一个很好的问题。
So in the early days, in the laboratory studies, researchers would give participants a growth mindset article and writing exercise, or a fixed mindset writing exercise and article. And then maybe moments later, ask them how much they believed intelligence could change. They'd measure their mindset. And maybe they'd give them a really hard puzzle to solve. and tell them it's measuring their intelligence, and see if people quit that puzzle or not. Once we started realizing that this idea had a little bit more power to potentially shape real-world behavior, we started going into real high schools and delivering this intervention,
在早期，在实验室研究中，研究人员会给参与者一篇成长型思维的文章和写作练习，或者一篇固定型思维的写作练习和文章。然后可能在片刻之后，询问他们有多相信智力是可以改变的。他们会测量他们的思维模式。然后他们可能会给他们一个非常难解的谜题，并告诉他们这正在测量他们的智力，以此观察人们是否会放弃这个谜题。一旦我们开始意识到这个理念具有更多重塑现实世界行为的潜力时，我们便开始进入真实的高中并开展这项干预，
and immediately afterward giving them a choice. The choice was, would you like to do more math problems today that will be very difficult, will push you to your limits but might teach you something new, or would you like some math problems that are very easy because they cover content you've already mastered, but you'll get to look smart because they're the kind of problems that you know all the answer to. And what we found is that, first of all,
并在紧接着让他们做一个选择。这个选择是，你今天想做更多非常困难的数学题吗？这些题目会把你推向极限，但可能会教给你一些新东西；或者你想做一些非常简单的数学题，因为它们涵盖了你已经掌握的内容，但你可以显得很聪明，因为它们是你已经知道所有答案的那类题目。我们发现，首先，
American teenagers, in a very large study we did, overwhelmingly chose the easy problems, not the hard problems, in the control group. And that's interesting because when I was a teacher, I spent all my time coming up with really demanding and rigorous learning opportunities. I wanted to have that challenging, you know, stand-and-deliver type curriculum. And yet, many of my students might shy away from that. And in fact, we find nationally many students shy away from that. What happened in the treatment group when students got the growth mindset?
在我们做的一项规模非常大的研究中，美国青少年在对照组中绝大多数都选择了简单的题目，而不是困难的题目。这很有趣，因为当我是一名教师时，我把所有的精力都花在了想出真正要求严格、严谨的学习机会上。我希望拥有那种具有挑战性的、你知道的“站着讲课”类型的课程。然而，我的许多学生却可能会对此退缩。事实上，我们发现全国范围内有许多学生对此退缩。当学生获得成长型思维时，实验组会发生什么？
What we found is rather striking increases in the rates at which students said, give me the hard problems. I want the ones that are going to teach me something new, even if I might sacrifice the chance to look like the smartest. And so that is one example of a kind of learning-oriented behavior that just feels more reasonable in a growth mindset. By the way, in the study I just described, we had schools across the country. We randomly selected public high schools across the U.S. and gave them this task. We call it the make-a-math worksheet task. And we found that pretty much consistently across the country, no matter what group students were from, what schools they're in,
我们发现，学生说“给我难题”的比率出现了惊人的增长。我想要那些能教给我新东西的题目，即使我可能会牺牲显得最聪明的机会。因此，这是成长型思维下感觉更合理的学习导向行为的一个例子。顺便说一句，在我刚描述的研究中，我们的学校遍布全国。我们随机选择了全美各地的公立高中并给他们布置了这项任务。我们称之为“制作数学工作表”任务。我们发现，在全国范围内基本保持一致，无论学生来自哪个群体，在什么学校，
growth mindset made students more willing to choose the hard math problems versus the easy math problems. So one of the aspects of your work that's really interesting, I think, is that the interventions that you're working with appear to decrease racial, socioeconomic, and other achievement gaps. Can you talk about that or growth mindset interventions most effective for students who are more at risk or do they work for everyone? In the study I just described, we find pretty consistently growth mindset will change, as long as students pay attention, it will change their attitudes and their behavior moments later. The more interesting part is, what happens if you come back three months, five months, six months, ten months, 12 months later? Are students grades higher? Are they taking the harder math courses? If they're college students, are they still full-time students? What we find in general is that overall students' grades tend to increase and they tend to take harder math classes.
成长型思维让学生更愿意选择困难的数学题，而不是简单的数学题。因此，我认为你工作中非常有趣的一个方面是，你所研究的干预措施似乎缩小了种族、社会经济和其他成就差距。你能谈谈这个吗，或者成长型思维干预对风险更高的学生最有效，还是对每个人都管用？在我刚刚描述的研究中，我们相当一致地发现，成长型思维将会改变——只要学生专心听讲——它会在片刻之后改变他们的态度和行为。更有趣的部分是，如果你在三个月、五月、六月、十月或十二月后来复查，会发生什么？学生的成绩更高了吗？他们是否在选修更难的数学课程？如果他们是大学生，他们仍然是全日制学生吗？我们总的发现是，总体而言，学生的成绩往往会有所提高，并且他们往往会选修更难的数学课。
But especially the grades effects are more striking for students who previously had lower grades, which in the U.S. are often students who are from families that have fewer socioeconomic resources or students from racial and ethnic minority backgrounds. In the college-going studies, we find the same kinds of results. So students of color and first-generation college students tend to benefit more in terms of their grades and course-taking from the growth mindset compared to students from more advantage backgrounds. The scientific puzzle, though, is, well, do the advantage students not need the mindset? Are they not listening to it? Or something else going on?
但特别是对于以前成绩较低的学生来说，成绩效应更为惊人，在美国，这些学生通常是来自社会经济资源较少的家庭的学生，或者是来自少数族裔和少数族群背景的学生。在关于大学生的研究中，我们发现了类似的结果。因此，与来自更有优势背景的学生相比，有色人种学生和第一代大学生往往能从成长型思维中获得更多成绩和选修课程方面的益处。然而，科学上的谜团是，那么占优势背景的学生就不需要这种思维模式吗？他们没有在听吗？还是有别的原因？
What we think is that students from groups that are negatively stereotyped in our society have to confirm. a lot of fixed mindset messaging. In fact, the idea that some groups are just inherently smarter than others is an explicit part of our country's history with segregation. In fact, that's a key part of the ideology that justified segregation prior to Brownview Board. And so, in many ways, what a growth mindset can do is allow a student to have a little bit of a reprieve from very prominent and prevalent ideas that to this day persist about members of
我们认为，在我们社会中被负面刻板印象化的群体的学生必须证实。大量的固定型思维信息传递。事实上，某些群体天生就比其他群体更聪明的观点，是我们国家种族隔离历史中一个明确的部分。事实上，这是在布朗诉教育委员会案之前为种族隔离辩护的意识形态的关键部分。因此，在许多方面，成长型思维可以做的是，让学生从至今仍然存在的关于成员的非常突出和普遍的观点中获得一点喘息的机会。
minority groups. And it may allow them to see themselves in this given educational setting as having the potential to grow and develop. So that's why we think that growth mindset is a promising way to try to address some of the persistent racial or socioeconomic inequalities. But we don't think it's the only way, and we certainly don't think it's a silver bullet. Have you only administered these interventions with respect to mathematics, or are you doing it in other subjects as well? We often do the interventions completely separate from content areas. So you might get it in health class or PE class or geology class. There's nothing about the intervention that needs to be delivered in a content area, but we often find effects in the most rigorous in anxiety-inducing
少数群体。它可能让他们在给定的教育环境中看到自己具有成长和发展的潜力。这就是为什么我们认为成长型思维是试图解决一些持续存在的种族或社会经济不平等问题的一个有前途的方法。但我们不认为它是唯一的方法，我们也绝对不认为它是灵丹妙药。你是否仅在数学方面实施过这些干预措施，还是也在其他科目中这样做？我们经常将干预措施与内容领域完全分开进行。所以你可能在健康课、体育课或地质课上获得它。干预措施没有什么必须在特定内容领域中交付的部分，但我们经常在最严格、最容易引发焦虑的课程中发现效果，
classes because those are the classes where students are most at risk for experiencing fixed mindset cultures. So there's another point that's a little not as interesting, which is simply that there's great inflation in English and history in U.S. public high schools and almost everyone gets an A already. So even if the treatment was working, it's harder to find out if it's working because the control group is already getting straight A's and the treatment group can't do any better. And measurement in math class is much more precise.
因为在这些课程中，学生最容易面临体验到固定型思维文化的风险。所以还有另一点不太有趣，那就是美国公立高中的英语和历史存在严重的通货膨胀，几乎每个人都能直接得A。因此，即使干预措施正在起作用，也很难弄清楚它是否起作用，因为对照组已经全拿A了，而实验组不可能做得更好。数学课上的测量要精确得多。
I mean, you get a numeric. Yeah, that GPA and math is like 2.3. And in English, it's like 3.0 on a 4-point scale. I understand there was some criticism in some corners that the paper that you published in nature didn't include the intervention that your colleagues administered to students. Why would you have left it out? And how does somebody get a copy if they want to use this technique? Yeah, I never understood that. Like a third of the intervention is in the online supplement so people can see all the important parts.
我的意思是，你会得到一个数字。是的，GPA在数学中大概是2.3。而在英语中，在4分制下大约是3.0。我了解到，有些角落有一些批评认为，你在《自然》杂志上发表的论文没有包含你的同事对学生实施的干预措施。你为什么把它漏掉了？如果有人想使用这项技术，他们该如何获取副本？是的，我从来不理解这一点。大约三分之一的干预措施在在线补充材料中，所以人们可以看到所有重要的部分。
The whole thing is available through our population research center, and that's listed in the article. So I never understood the motivations of people who wanted to claim that, and it's kind of a weird myth that persists. The truth is that if you make it freely available, then private. companies will take it and sell it and say, nature already showed this works. And then there will be lots of deceptive marketing around a really promising idea and claims being made about what we're doing. And so anyone who wants to do research with it can access it. We just don't allow private companies or people who are going to misuse the materials to use them without request. I mean, it's like saying, it's like saying you read a paper on the COVID vaccine and you can't download the COVID vaccine.
全部内容都可以通过我们的群组研究中心获取，文章中列出了这一点。所以我从来不理解那些想要那样声称的人的动机，这是一种持续存在的奇怪神话。事实是，如果你把它免费提供，那么私营。公司会拿去售卖，并说《自然》杂志已经证明这管用了。然后，围绕一个非常有前途的理念，就会有大量具欺骗性的营销，并且对我们正在做的事情做出各种声明。因此，任何想用它做研究的人都可以访问它。我们只是不允许私营公司或那些会滥用这些材料的人在未经请求的情况下使用它们。我的意思是，这就像说，这就像说你读了一篇关于新冠疫苗的论文，却不能下载新冠疫苗。
That's what it's like saying. Because of course the companies who develop the COVID vaccine should then own the intellectual property and people can replicate the results if they'd like. But it doesn't mean that anyone who reads the paper is entitled to proprietary information. So I just never understood that. But I do think it's critical at a higher level for people to continue to replicate. and we have. We have lots of independent replications. We've shared it. But also to develop new materials and make them better. And I think we welcome any scientific inquiry to improve the materials and to try to understand how to improve people's lives.
情况就是这样。因为开发新冠疫苗的公司当然应该拥有知识产权，如果人们愿意，他们可以复制结果。但这并不意味着任何阅读该论文的人都有权获得专有信息。所以我从来不理解这一点。但我确实认为，从更高的层面来看，人们继续进行复制至关重要。我们已经这样做了。我们有很多独立的复制。我们已经分享了它。而且还要开发新材料并使之更好。我认为我们欢迎任何旨在改进材料并试图了解如何改善人们生活的科学探求。
Well, that makes sense. And I certainly just wanted to raise that because I had heard that that was your response as well. You're also studying growth mindset in teachers, right? And whether your teacher's understanding of mindset makes a difference in their students' outcomes. What are you finding? In our national study done in the U.S., the first pass at which was published in nature, we looked at school cultures and found that school cultures undermine the treatment effect if they support more fixed mindset behaviors. But school cultures enhance the treatment effect if they support more growth mindset behaviors.
嗯，这说得通。我当然只是想提出这一点，因为我也听说那是你的回应。你也在研究教师身上的成长型思维，对吧？并且研究教师对思维模式的理解是否会对外在学生的成果产生影响。你们发现了什么？在我们于美国进行的国家级研究中，其初步成果发表在《自然》杂志上，我们研究了学校文化，发现如果学校文化支持更多固定型思维行为，它就会破坏治疗效果。但如果学校文化支持更多成长型思维行为，它就会增强治疗效果。
So if you go back to that worksheet task I mentioned, where students can choose the easier the hard problems, there are some schools where in the control group, students are already saying, yes, give me more hard math problems. And some schools where they're saying, no, I want the easy problems. And you can, reading between the lines, it's as though kids might be made fun of for raising their hand and saying, yes, math teacher, please give me harder math problems, right? And before we did the study, we didn't know in which kind of school the treatment would work better or worse. So would it work better in the schools that have supportive peer norms because the peers need to reinforce the short mindset message? Or would it work better in the schools that have unsupportive norms? Because that's where you need it the most. And we kind of had a debate between the psychologists and the sociologists on our team.
所以如果你回到我之前提到那个工作表任务，学生可以选择简单或困难的题目，有些学校在对照组中，学生已经说：“是的，给我更多的难数学题吧。”而有些学校则说：“不，我想要简单的题目。”你可以透过现象看本质，这就好像孩子们如果举手说：“是的，数学老师，请给我出更难的数学题吧”时，可能会被嘲笑一样，对吧？在我们做这项研究之前，我们并不知道在哪种学校里干预会更有效或更无效。那么，它会在具有支持性同伴规范的学校里效果更好吗？因为同伴需要强化简短的思维模式信息。或者它会在缺乏支持性规范的学校里效果更好吗？因为那是你最需要它的时候。我们团队中的心理学家和 sociologists（社会学家）之间进行了一场辩论。
Sociologists, as you know, think about the context. they want to think about social structures and focus less on the individual. Psychologists, our bias is that we kind of put too much on the minds of the individual and under-emphasize the importance of organizations. And what did we find? It turns out that sociologists were right.
如你所知，社会学家思考背景。他们想要思考社会结构，而较少关注个人。心理学家，我们的偏见是，我们在一定程度上把太多注意力放在个人的头脑上，而低估了组织的重要性。我们发现了什么？事实证明，社会学家是对的。
The sociologists predicted that the supportive norms would be necessary to sustain the mindset intervention. And that's what the data showed. In the next study, the next follow-up paper that hopefully will come out soon. We zoomed in on the classroom. We surveyed teachers and asked them about their mindsets. And what we found is that when teachers reported more of a growth mindset, that's where you got
社会学家预测，支持性的规范对于维持思维模式干预是必要的。数据也确实显示了这一点。在下一项研究中，即希望很快发表的下一篇后续论文中。我们将镜头拉近到了课堂。我们调查了教师，询问了他们的思维模式。我们发现，当教师表现出更多的成长型思维时，你就会获得。
bigger treatment effects. When teachers reported more of a fixed mindset, you got nothing. In both kinds of classrooms, you can change the mindset, you can change the behavior, but you don't change the grades at the end of the year unless the teacher has a supportive growth mindset. So what are we doing now? Well, instead of just saying, well, it looks like you can't give the treatment in a supportive context, which would be kind of a disappointing conclusion if you want to use the treatment to address problems with motivation, or instead saying, how can we begin to change classroom culture? How can we change the peer culture and the teacher beliefs so that in places where previously the treatment would not have worked,
更大的干预效果。当教师表现出更多的固定型思维时，你什么也得不到。在这两种类型的课堂中，你可以改变思维模式，你可以改变行为，但除非教师具有支持性的成长型思维，否则你无法改变年底的成绩。那么我们现在在做什么呢？好吧，我们没有说“看起来你不能在支持性的背景下提供干预”——如果你想用干预来解决动机问题，这将是一个令人失望的结论，而是去探讨：我们如何开始改变课堂文化？我们如何改变同伴文化和教师信念，以便在以前干预无法起作用的地方，
now the treatment could work? And it turns out that's a very hard question to answer because now we're thinking of changing adults in their professional roles. And as everyone knows, it's hard to change adults, especially in our professional settings. Adults are nested within bosses who have certain expectations. Teachers, for instance, are beholden to the school boards that they're in. They have many demands on their time. They're constantly being asked to do whatever the latest policy. fat is. And so rather than kind of throw up our hands and say, we're just going to have to take
现在干预可以起作用了？事实证明，这是一个很难回答的问题，因为现在我们考虑的是改变处于职业角色的成年人。众所周知，改变成年人是很难的，尤其是在我们的职业环境中。成年人的头上顶着有特定期望的老板。例如，教师受制于他们所在的学校董事会。他们的时间面临许多要求。他们不断被要求执行最新的政策。
the, you know, take it that the treatment doesn't work in certain settings, we're trying to mobilize scientists and practitioners to look at the problem of teacher behavior change and the cultures they create as the next great scientific challenge. And I think it's essential that we do it if we're going to meet the demands of overcoming the current crisis we're in. with respect to education and student engagement. What, if any, work is happening about getting this concept into curriculum for people who are studying to become teachers? I've often thought that growth mindset should be a part of teacher education, and it is in many ways.
时髦的东西。因此，与其两手一摊说，我们只能接受。你知道，认为干预在某些环境下不起作用，我们正试图动员科学家和实践者将教师行为改变的问题以及他们创造的文化视为下一个伟大的科学挑战。我认为，如果我们想要满足克服我们目前所处的危机的要求，这样做是至关重要的。在教育和学生参与度方面。关于将这个概念纳入成为教师的学生的课程中，正在开展什么工作（如果有的话）？我经常认为成长型思维应该成为教师教育的一部分，在许多方面它确实是。
However, researchers, we kind of need to get our act together and provide more direct evidence for teachers who want to use growth mindset on a daily basis as a part of their routines and rituals. And we haven't yet provided the guidance that teachers need, I think, to implement these ideas with fidelity and with high impact. We have far more confidence in the student mindset interventions because of the level of testing and evaluation. But on the teacher's side, you know, what are the practices they need to have? Is it enough to put up a poster on the wall to say have a growth mindset? Or does something deeper need to happen? So, I think schools of education are a beautiful means for using this evidence, and I think there's a
然而，作为研究人员，我们需要振作起来，为那些希望在日常工作和常规中将成长型思维作为一部分的教师提供更直接的证据。我认为，我们尚未提供教师有效且高影响力地实施这些理念所需的指导。由于测试和评估的水平，我们对学生思维模式干预有更大的信心。但在教师这一端，你知道，他们需要有哪些做法？在墙上贴一张海报说“拥有成长型思维”就足够了吗？还是需要发生更深层次的事情？因此，我认为教育学院是利用这些证据的一个绝佳途径，而且我认为存在着一种。
hunger for it because of the growing attention to social and emotional learning. But the research really needs to be accelerated, and we need to start learning from expert practitioners so that we can do it more quickly. So I mentioned in my introduction that you often focus on helping students at times of transition, like when they're starting high school or college. What role does timing play in these interventions? So I'm a developmental psychologist primarily, and I'm informed in part by classic models of the importance of a life transition. Glenn Elder is a classic sociologist who developed these ideas, along with my mentor, Rob Krosno. And what we think that transitions do is they create an openness to new ways of thinking and new habits.
由于对社交和情感学习的日益关注，人们对它有着强烈的渴望。但研究确实需要加速，我们需要开始向专家实践者学习，以便我们能更快地做到这一点。所以我刚才在介绍中提到，你经常专注于在人生过渡期帮助学生，比如他们刚开始上高中或大学时。时机在这些干预中起什么作用？所以，我主要是一名发展心理学家，我的部分观点受到关于生命过渡重要性的经典模型的启发。格伦·埃尔德（Glenn Elder）是一位经典的社会学家，他与我的导师罗布·克罗斯诺（Rob Krosno）一起发展了这些理念。我们认为过渡的作用是，它们创造了一种对新思维方式和新习惯的开放性。
So an example of a transition is transition from middle school to high school. or high school to college. But other transitions are from being, from not having children to having children, from being in the military back into civilian life, or vice versa, from going from civilian into military life. In each of these examples and in many others, what you see is that you're in a new role that you don't quite know how to master, and you see lots of ambiguity. You see supervisors who are giving you feedback. Does this mean they believe in me or that they're going to kick me out? You may have a hard time finding the right people to rely on and to turn to, right?
因此，过渡的一个例子是从初中过渡到高中。或者从高中到大学。但其他的过渡是从没有孩子到有孩子，从军队回到平民生活，或者反过来，从平民生活进入军队生活。在每一个这样的例子以及许多其他例子中，你所看到的是，你处于一个你还不太知道如何掌握的新角色中，而且你看到了很多模糊性。你看到主管在给你反馈。这是否意味着他们相信你，还是他们要把你踢出去？你可能很难找到合适的人来依靠和求助，对吧？
You may not know if the abilities you have now are ever going to be up to the level that they need to be to succeed in this new setting. Right. So there's a lot of discomfort, a lot of questioning, a lot of ambiguity. In those moments, we think that seemingly, small differences in your overall belief system can lead to self-reinforcing cycles in positive or negative directions. Let's take the example of a ninth grader with a fixed mindset in this transition to high school math, right? High school math should be harder than your middle school math if it's doing its job. It's supposed to be preparing you for the next level, right? But a student with a fixed mindset may interpret that as, wow, this class is harder than what I could do. I should drop,
你可能不知道你现在的能力是否能达到在这个新环境中取得成功所需的水平。没错。因此，会有很多不适、很多质疑、很多模糊性。在这些时刻，我们认为你的整体信念系统看似微小的差异，可能会导致朝向积极或消极方向的自我强化循环。让我们以一个在升入高中数学的过渡期中持有固定型思维的九年级学生为例，对吧？如果高中数学能发挥其作用，它应该比你的初中数学更难。它应该为你的下一级做好准备，对吧？但持有固定型思维的学生可能会将其解释为：“哇，这门课比我能应付的要难。我应该退课，
maybe to the lower level class, or I should be ashamed of how much I don't know, and I should keep that lack of knowledge is secret. I shouldn't study in groups. I shouldn't raise my hand, and so on. And so the interpretation of the difficulty leads to early stage behaviors that then cause a student to underperform on the next quiz or test. Now they've underperformed on the quiz or test. They may say, wow, I guess I was right. I'm not that smart at this. And that's a, So the worry becomes reluctance to behave in a pro-learning way, which becomes low performance, which becomes evidence that feeds into more worry, right? That's what Jeff Cohen calls a recursive process.
也许降到较低水平的班级，或者我应该为自己不知道的东西感到羞耻，我应该把这种缺乏知识的情况保密。我不应该在小组里学习。我不应该举手，等等。”因此，对困难的解释导致了早期的行为，这反过来又导致学生在下一次小测验或考试中表现不佳。现在他们在小测验或考试中表现不佳了。他们可能会说：“哇，我猜我是对的。我在这个方面不太聪明。”这是一个，因此，担忧变成了对以学习为导向的行为的抗拒，这变成了低表现，而这又变成了滋生更多担忧的证据，对吧？这就是杰夫·科恩（Jeff Cohen）所说的递归过程。
So in a growth mindset, though, a small shift in a belief about the meaning of difficulty could lead a student to interpret that same early challenge at the beginning of ninth grade as a normal part of meeting ambitious learning goals. I chose a hard math class because I believe in myself and I want to go far. This math, of course, it's hard. This is a challenging course. And I see many other students who are also struggling. If I continue doing the work and asking for help, then I'm going to get better at this.
然而，在成长型思维中，对困难含义的信念发生微小转变，可能会导致学生将九年级刚开始时遇到的同样早期的挑战，解释为实现宏伟学习目标的正常部分。我选择了困难的数学课，因为我相信自己，我想走得更远。这门数学，当然，它是困难的。这是一门具有挑战性的课程。而且我看到许多其他学生也在挣扎。如果我继续做作业并寻求帮助，那么我会在这方面变得更好。
And then I'll be ready for the next challenge. And I'll feel confused then. Student may then go to the teacher and say, I'm struggling on this one thing. Can you help me explain it? Or to peers, you guys understand this. can you tell me how you got it? This isn't with a growth mindset
然后我就会为下一个挑战做好准备。那时我会感到困惑。学生随后可能会去找老师说：“我在这一件事上挣扎。你能帮我解释一下吗？”或者对同伴说：“你们懂这个。能告诉我你们是怎么做出来的吗？”这并不是带有成长型思维的人
may not fear the same kind of shame, may not have the same kind of worries, and then do the small behaviors that lead to the better performance that then becomes positive evidence and leads to less worry about ability. And that's what Jeff Cohen calls, a positive recursive process.
可能不会害怕同样的羞耻，可能不会有同样的担忧，然后做出那些带来更好表现的小行为，这些小行为随后成为积极的证据，并减少对能力的担忧。这就是杰夫·科恩（Jeff Cohen）所说的积极的递归过程。
So it's not like we think growth mindset doesn't matter at other times, but we think that when there's so much up in the air in a life transition, that's the time where a small difference in beliefs or like a Bayesian base rate can lead to a just slightly different probability of either a pro-learning or an anti-learning behavior that over time could become self-reinforcing. There's another theory in psychology that's gotten a lot of attention recently, Angela Duckworth's
所以并不是说我们认为成长型思维在其他时间不重要，而是我们认为，当在生命过渡期有如此多的不确定因素时，正是信念上的微小差异——就像贝叶斯基础比率一样——可能导致对促进学习或抗拒学习的行为产生略微不同的概率，而这些行为随着时间推移会变得具有自我强化性。心理学中最近备受关注的另一个理论是安杰拉·达克沃思（Angela Duckworth）的
concept of grit. And I'm just wondering, what's the difference between growth mindset and grit? Are they related? Well, they're correlated, but which isn't saying much. I mean, almost every good academic behavior is correlated with almost every other good academic behavior. You know, there are different concepts. Angela would argue, and I think it's probably true, that growth mindset is one possible antecedent of grit. And one way to promote gritty persistence in the face of failure is to help people believe that that failure is not
“坚毅”（grit）概念。我只想知道，成长型思维和坚毅有什么区别？它们有关联吗？嗯，它们是相关的，但这说明不了什么。我的意思是，几乎每一个好的学术行为都与几乎每一个其他好的学术行为相关。你知道，它们是不同的概念。安杰拉会认为，而且我认为这可能是真的，成长型思维是坚毅的一个可能的先行条件。促进面对失败时的坚毅坚持的一种方法是帮助人们相信这种失败并不是
debilitating, but instead is a means through which you can become stronger. I think the differences between the two concepts mainly stem from the different traditions that they come from. Grit is kind of coming from a personality individual differences perspective. You know, what explains variation in people's performance over time, especially among people who are already positively selected to be good at a thing. So among West Point cadets, what distinguishes West Point cadets who continue versus not, right? Among elite spelling B people, what distinguishes people who win the spelling B versus come in 20th, right? And grit, I think, really plays a role in those types of settings.
削弱性的，相反，它是你可以变得更强的一种手段。我认为这两个概念之间的差异主要源于它们来自不同的传统。坚毅有点来自于人格个体差异的视角。你知道，是什么解释了人们随时间推移的表现差异，尤其是在那些已经被积极挑选出来擅长某项事物的人群之中？因此，在西点军校学员中，是什么区分了坚持下去的西点军校学员与没有坚持下去的学员，对吧？在精英拼写比赛的人群中，是什么区分了赢得拼写比赛的人与获得第20名的人，对吧？我认为坚毅确实在这些类型的环境中发挥作用。
Mindset is coming out of a social cognitive tradition. And what I mean by that is it's more about the ways that we interpret the world, the meaning we make out of it. It's more likely to be socialized by the things we overhear, parents say, that we see on TV. about ability and so on. And those different traditions are not superficial because they actually lead to different predictions about how to promote the different constructs. So I would say that grit and growth mindset
思维模式则是从社会认知传统中走出来的。我的意思是，它更多地关于我们解释世界的方式，我们从中赋予的意义。它更有可能通过我们无意中听到的父母所说的话、我们在电视上看到的关于能力的言论等来进行社会化。这些不同的传统并不是肤浅的，因为它们实际上对如何促进不同的结构做出了不同的预测。所以我会说，坚毅和成长型思维
are very friendly cousins, and they predict different things and they work in different ways, but they get together for family reunions all the time. I like the image. You talk about, in your research, you had this huge cohort of students from across the country, are you looking to implement the same kind of testing with students in other countries? I'm just wondering, because as you talk about
是非常友好的表亲，它们预测不同的事情，并以不同的方式起作用，但它们一直聚在一起参加家庭聚会。我喜欢这个比喻。你谈到在你的研究中，你拥有这个来自全国各地的庞大宏大群体，你是否希望在其他国家的学生身上实施同等类型的测试？我只是在想，因为正如你所谈到的
American students wanting to take the easy way out, might it be that students in other cultures would behave differently just from the get-go? Are you looking at that? Yeah, I'm really glad you raised that because just last week, the OECD... Oh, you're going to have to explain that OECD... Yeah, OECD is an international economic development organization. So there are 78 or so nations in the world that are considered OECD nations. And OECD provides guidance on things like health care and education. But one of the important things they do is they administer an international test called the PISA, P-I-S-A. And in 2008, they had 600,000 students from around the world.
美国学生想要走捷径，会不会其他文化背景的学生从一开始就会有不同的表现呢？你在关注这一点吗？是的，我很高兴你提出这一点，因为就在上周，OECD……哦，你得解释一下什么是OECD……是的，OECD是一个国际经济发展组织。所以世界上大约有78个被认为是OECD国家的国家。OECD就医疗保健和教育等方面提供指导。但他们所做的一项重要工作是管理一项名为PISA（国际学生评估项目）的国际测试，即P-I-S-A。在2008年，他们有来自世界各地的60万名学生。
And in each nation that they collected data from, they had about four to six thousand students that were randomly selected from the population. So we're talking random samples from all developing countries in the world. And those students in that test completed a comprehensive assessment of reading and math skills, but they also completed a very long survey. And on that survey was some growth mindset measures. and also measures where students rated the mindset supportiveness of their teachers. So what did the PISA find in their report? Well, first they find that growth mindset predicts achievement around the world. And something like 72 out of 77 nations, growth mindset positively predicts higher test scores among 15-year-olds, which is what we've focused on often in our research.
在他们收集数据的每一个国家，他们从人口中随机选择了大约四到五千名学生。所以我们谈论的是来自世界上所有发展中国家的随机样本。该测试中的学生完成了对阅读和数学技能的全面评估，但他们也完成了一份非常长的调查。在该调查中，有一些成长型思维的测量指标，
So that's really interesting. Well, what about the countries where growth mindset does not predict test scores? Interestingly, they're almost all East Asian countries. So three of them are regions of China. And it's like, okay, that's interesting. Well, does growth mindset not matter in East Asian cultures? That doesn't seem right because certainly the fixed mindset fear that you're not smart could be stressful for anyone.
以及学生评估其教师对思维模式支持程度的指标。那么PISA在其报告中发现了什么呢？首先，他们发现成长型思维可以预测世界各地的学业成就。在大约77个国家中的72个国家里，成长型思维能够积极预测15岁青少年的更高测试分数，这也是我们研究中经常关注的对象。
But it turns out that the PISA has discovered a secret to the puzzle. As it happens, the countries where mindset does not predict test scores, mindset predicts well-being the best. So a fear of failure, a fear of letting people down, a worry that you'll be revealed as inadequate. A lot of these mental health, stress, and well-being measures show the strongest course, relations with growth mindset in the countries where the measure of growth mindset does not predict achievement. So what's the answer to the puzzle? Well, in a lot of the East Asian countries, students are already doing 40 hours of school
所以这真的很有趣。那么，成长型思维不能预测测试分数的国家呢？有趣的是，它们几乎全部是东亚国家。其中三个是中国的不同地区。这就像是，好吧，这很有趣。难道成长型思维在东亚文化中不重要吗？这似乎不太对，因为固定的、担心自己不够聪明的思维模式对任何人来说肯定都是充满压力的。
work a week outside of their regular school time. So if you have a growth mindset, you can't really do much more math homework and science homework. It's amazing. But if you have a fixed mindset, you could definitely worry that you're failing your family in your community if you're not seeming smart. And so I think what it really invites us to do is to look for more puzzles like that internationally and say, how do we go from the old world of saying, is growth mindset real
但事实证明，PISA发现了这个谜题的秘密。巧合的是，思维模式不能预测测试分数的国家，思维模式对福祉的预测效果最好。所以，对失败的恐惧、对让别人失望的恐惧、担心自己被揭露为不合格。许多这些心理健康、压力和福祉的测量指标显示，在成长型思维测量无法预测学业成就的国家中，与成长型思维的相关性最强。那么这个谜题的答案是什么呢？在许多东亚国家，学生在常规学校时间之外，每周已经要做40小时的学校
or not? Does it predict things or not? Into the new world of saying, where does it not predict outcomes? How might it predict other outcomes? And what are the cultural factors at play? So I think the future is really going to be learning from those differences across cultures and that heterogeneity. And the PISA result, which I encourage everyone to look at the report, is going to be a very fascinating launching point for that new research. Well, this has been really interesting, Dr. Yeager.
作业。因此，如果你拥有成长型思维，你其实做不了更多数学和科学作业了。这太惊人了。但如果你拥有固定型思维，如果你看起来不够聪明，你绝对会担心自己辜负了你的家庭和社区。因此，我认为它真正邀请我们做的是在国际上去寻找更多这样的谜题，并说：我们如何从旧的世界——即“成长型思维是真是假？它能预测事情还是不能？”——走向新的世界——即“它在哪些地方无法预测结果？它可能会预测哪些其他结果？起作用的文化因素又是什么？”所以，我认为未来真正要向这些跨文化的差异和这种异质性学习。而PISA的结果——我鼓励每个人都去看看那份报告——将成为这项新研究一个非常迷人的出发点。好吧，这真的非常有趣，耶格尔博士。
I appreciate your joining us today and talking to us about your research and wish you luck in your future endeavors. Thank you very much. You can read more about Dr. Yeager's work in the April May issue of APA's magazine. monitor on psychology, just go to www.apa.org slash monitor. And you can find previous episodes of speaking of psychology at www.spicingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, email us at speaking of psychology at apa.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman.
感谢您今天加入我们并跟我们探讨您的研究，祝您未来的工作一切顺利。非常感谢。您可以阅读APA杂志《心理学观察》（Monitor on Psychology）4月/5月刊中有关叶格博士工作的更多文章，只需访问 www.apa.org/monitor。您还可以在 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 以及您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学感知》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，请发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。即 speakingofpsychology，全部连在一起，@apa.org。《心理学感知》由李·韦内曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。
Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音效编辑是克里斯·孔迪汉（Chris Condihan）。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。